This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the Arctic Ocean, there's a cluster of islands called Svalbard. The islands are technically part of Norway, but they're much farther north than the mainland. Like way, way up toward the North Pole. The landscape is icy and mountainous, and on one of the icy mountains of Svalbard is a very curious thing. A vault. The entrance to the vault itself is small but striking. It's like a man-made obelisk sticking out of a glacier on top of a mountain.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在北冰洋，有一群岛屿叫斯瓦尔巴群岛。这些岛屿名义上属于挪威，但它们比挪威大陆更靠北。就像是远远地向北极点延伸。这里的地貌冰冷多山，而在斯瓦尔巴群岛的一座冰山上，有一件非常奇特的东西。一个金库。金库本身的入口很小，但很引人注目。它就像一个矗立在山顶冰川上的人造方尖碑。
Yes, the vault itself is inside a mountain. That's Ben Brock Johnson from the podcast Endless Thread, a show in which Ben and his co-host Amri Seaverson tell stories that they find on Reddit. This week we're featuring one of those stories, so I'm going to hand this one off to Ben and Amri. This story has actually been posted a few times by different redditors, but it's about people who aren't necessarily redditors. Haga, Marie Haga.
是的，金库本身就在山里。那是来自播客《无尽线索》的本·布洛克·约翰逊，在这个节目中，本和他的联合主持人阿姆里·西弗森讲述他们在Reddit上发现的故事。本周我们特别呈现其中一个故事，所以我打算把这个故事交给本和阿姆里。这个故事实际上已经被不同的Reddit用户发布过几次了，但它讲的是那些不一定是Reddit用户的人。哈加，玛丽·哈加。
Do you think Marie Haga is a redditor, Ben? I don't know, but she definitely knows how to talk to interviewers. Do you want very short answers, medium answers? Marie Haga is a former Norwegian diplomat. She was a member of Parliament in that country, former Minister of Energy. Her current job is to manage one of the world's most important vaults, maybe the most important vault in the world. Let me take you on a little tour.
你觉得玛丽·哈加是Reddit用户吗，本？我不知道，但她绝对知道如何与采访者交谈。你想要非常简短的回答，还是中等长度的回答？玛丽·哈加是一位前挪威外交官。她曾是该国议会议员，前能源部长。她目前的工作是管理世界上最重要的金库之一，也许是世界上最重要的金库。让我带你参观一下。
Alright Marie, lead us into this glacier mountain. You open these metal doors. It's like something out of a science fiction novel. And you walk 130 meters into the mountains through a tunnel. The walls are covered in snow and ice. Heck, they look like they're made out of snow and ice. There's this big chamber. That I normally call the cathedral.
好了玛丽，带我们走进这座冰川山吧。你打开这些金属门。这就像科幻小说里的场景。你穿过一条隧道，走进山里130米。墙壁上覆盖着雪和冰。天哪，它们看起来就像是用雪和冰做成的。这里有一个大房间。我通常称之为大教堂。
It's painted white. It's a lot of ice crystals there. In this big room, you see three doors. These doors lead into three vaults. Vaults within the vault. What's inside? The precious treasure that is stored on permafrosti reindeer covered islands in the Arctic Ocean by a bunch of Norwegians. Behind the ICIS vault door at zero degrees Fahrenheit. Boxes, boxes, boxes, and boxes of seeds.
它被漆成了白色。那里有很多冰晶。在这个大房间里，你看到了三扇门。这些门通向三个金库。金库里的金库。里面有什么？那是被一群挪威人储存在北冰洋永久冻土驯鹿覆盖岛屿上的珍贵宝藏。在华氏零度的冰冷金库门后。一箱、一箱、又一箱的种子。
Seeds. Inside of these metal envelopes, 500 seeds per envelope. The seeds are from all over the world, and I mean all over the world, every country. It's part of something called the crop trust. The crop trust is like this massive backup for the planet's every country. It's part of something called the crop trust. The crop trust is like this massive backup for the planet's food crops. There's only one backup and this is it. And it's all
种子。在这些金属信封里，每个信封有500颗种子。这些种子来自世界各地，我是说世界各地，每一个国家。它是“作物信托”项目的一部分。作物信托就像是为地球上每个国家的粮食作物提供的一个巨大的备份。它是“作物信托”项目的一部分。作物信托就像是为地球上每个国家的粮食作物提供的一个巨大的备份。只有一个备份，就是这个。而且这一切
thanks to a Russian guy with a crazy story. Don't worry that's coming. But right now, how about a list of seeds in the backup from Marie Haga, whose official title is director of the crop trust? Haga, whose official title is Director of the Crop Trust. So we are concerned to safeguard the 3,000 varieties of coconuts, or the 4.5,000 varieties of potatoes. The 35,000 varieties of corn, the 125,000 varieties of wheat, or the 200,000 varieties of rice, just to mention some examples. There seems to be kind of a Noah's Ark aspect to this. That is actually a good description.
都要归功于一个有着疯狂故事的俄罗斯人。别担心，故事马上就来。但现在，先来看看玛丽·哈加提供的备份种子清单，她的正式头衔是作物信托基金主任。哈加，她的正式头衔是作物信托基金主任。所以我们致力于保护3000个品种的椰子，或者4500个品种的土豆。35000个品种的玉米，125000个品种的小麦，或者200000个品种的水稻，仅举几例。这似乎有一种诺亚方舟的感觉。这确实是一个很好的描述。
It is kind of a Noah's Ark of seeds. And it is meant to be a backup if things go wrong around the world, and unfortunately things do go wrong around the world occasionally. Once a decade, Spalbart staff is supposed to take new seeds into the vault. This is going to happen just a few weeks after this episode comes out on February 26th, 2018. Marie Haga and her team will disarm the vaults alarm systems, turn on the lights to the long tunnel into the mountain, unlock and creak open the vaults big doors, and put more seeds inside.
它确实有点像种子的诺亚方舟。它的目的是作为世界各地出现问题时的备份，不幸的是，世界各地偶尔确实会出问题。每十年，斯瓦尔巴的工作人员应该把新的种子带进金库。这将在本集播出几周后的2018年2月26日发生。玛丽·哈加和她的团队将解除金库的警报系统，打开通往山里长隧道的灯，解锁并吱呀一声打开金库的大门，放入更多的种子。
Any country that wants to store seeds in the vault can do it for free. And Marie says, in the vault, there is world peace. South Korea's seeds sit next to North Korea's seeds. There are seeds from Iraq sitting in the frigid silence. Afghanistan, Syria. Seeds from Ukraine sit next to seeds from Russia. It's almost like this is the one thing
任何想要在金库中储存种子的国家都可以免费进行。玛丽说，在金库里，有世界和平。韩国的种子和朝鲜的种子放在一起。有来自伊拉克的种子静静地躺在严寒中。阿富汗，叙利亚。来自乌克兰的种子和来自俄罗斯的种子放在一起。这几乎就像这是唯一一件
the whole world can get behind, protecting our food supply, in case of an emergency, like a big emergency. This single backup, this planet's worth of crop diversity, living in relative peace under a mountain, the spirit of this has its origins in World War II, a global existential crisis like no other. Svalbard story starts actually not too far away in Russia. The guy you could call Svalbard's story starts actually not too far away in Russia. The guy you could call Svalbard's Seed Vault's grandfather was a man named Nikolai Vavlov.
全世界都能支持的事情，保护我们的粮食供应，以防紧急情况，比如重大紧急情况。这唯一的备份，这地球上所有的作物多样性，在山下相对和平地生活着，这种精神起源于第二次世界大战，一场前所未有的全球生存危机。斯瓦尔巴的故事实际上起源于离这里不远的俄罗斯。你可以称之为斯瓦尔巴故事的起源实际上离俄罗斯不远。你可以称之为斯瓦尔巴种子库祖父的人是一个名叫尼古拉·瓦维洛夫的人。
I don't know what the crop trust my organization would have been without Vavilov. He really explained to the world back in the early 1900s how we globally are fully interdependent when it comes to crops. The crazy part of Vavlov's story, though, is that this man, a giant in the world of crop genetics, was thrown in a Russian gulag for his scientific principles. And a bunch of his devoted co-workers had to fend off rats and starvation to protect his life's work. The richest seed supply the world had ever seen, hidden away, underground, in its own vault. And what is now the city of St. Petersburg?
我不知道如果没有瓦维洛夫，我的组织作物信托会是什么样子。他在20世纪初真正向世界解释了我们在作物方面是如何在全球范围内完全相互依存的。然而，瓦维洛夫故事中最疯狂的部分是，这个人在作物遗传学界是一个巨人，却因为他的科学原则被扔进了俄罗斯的古拉格集中营。他的一群忠诚的同事不得不抵御老鼠和饥饿来保护他毕生的心血。世界上见过的最丰富的种子储备，被隐藏在地下，在它自己的金库里。而现在圣彼得堡市是什么样子？
Back then, though, it had a different name. Leningrad, and Leningrad was under siege. Okay, you know how people say so-and-so wrote the book on X? Well, agricultural ecologist ethno-botnist and Franciscan brother Gary Nabhenn wrote the book on our Russian botnist Nikolai Vavlov. Well, Vavivlov was from a very well-educated family in Russia, I think every one of his siblings became a scientist as well. The book is called Where Our Food Comes From, retracing Nikolai Bavlov's quest to end famine. In the circle of life, Garry's book shows
不过当时，它有一个不同的名字。列宁格勒，而列宁格勒当时正处于被围困之中。好吧，你知道人们怎么说某某人写了关于X的书吗？嗯，农业生态学家、民族植物学家和方济各会修士加里·纳布汉写了关于我们俄罗斯植物学家尼古拉·瓦维洛夫的书。嗯，瓦维洛夫来自俄罗斯一个受过良好教育的家庭，我想他的每一个兄弟姐妹也都成为了科学家。这本书叫《我们的食物来自哪里》，追溯了尼古拉·瓦维洛夫结束饥荒的追求。在生命循环中，加里的书展示了
that this Russian botanist and geneticist story really begins in famine just like it ends. The grew up in a period where Russia and Eastern Europe had suffered one famine after another due to inclement weather causing crop failures. These famines that he grew up with, how serious were they? They were of epic proportions from the 1860s on. There were six major famines that killed over a half million people in Eastern Europe and Russia.
这位俄罗斯植物学家和遗传学家的故事确实始于饥荒，也终于饥荒。他成长在一个俄罗斯和东欧因恶劣天气导致作物歉收而遭受一次又一次饥荒的时期。他成长的这些饥荒有多严重？从19世纪60年代开始，它们就达到了史诗般的规模。有六次大饥荒，在东欧和俄罗斯造成了超过50万人死亡。
And so he grew up in this milieu. Tolstoy was writing about the... Vavlov's upbringing around these horrendous crop failures in famines leads him to learn a ton about plants and botany. And as he is doing his work as a botanist in the 1920s, he starts to get into this idea that collecting the plants or the seeds, preserving and understanding crop diversity around the world, might help fight off crop failures because he might be able to breathe the plants and find certain strains that could resist bad weather and thus famine. There were people with their eyes on the same prize earlier on in history, Thomas Jefferson,
所以他就是在这种环境中长大的。托尔斯泰当时正在写关于……瓦维洛夫在这些可怕的作物歉收和饥荒中的成长经历，使他学到了大量关于植物和植物学的知识。当他在20世纪20年代作为植物学家工作时，他开始产生这样一个想法：收集植物或种子，保存和了解世界各地的作物多样性，可能有助于抵御作物歉收，因为他可能能够培育植物并找到某些能抵抗恶劣天气从而抵抗饥荒的品种。历史上早就有人的目光盯着同样的奖赏，托马斯·杰斐逊，
for example, who collected seeds and brought back cuttings of plants to the Americas. But Vavilov was the first one who had the education in what we would call Olaf was the first one who had the education in what we would call evolutionary biology, how plants adapt to different climates and conditions. He had sort of this humanitarian set of values that underscored the way he did science and sort of a remarkable way. I mean, he really was a superstar up there with Charles Darwin and other people that we could mention. So we've been talking about Nikolai Vavlov, who by many measures is one of the world's
例如，他收集种子并把植物插条带回美洲。但瓦维洛夫是第一个受过我们所说的进化生物学教育的人，了解植物如何适应不同的气候和条件。他有一种人道主义价值观，以一种非凡的方式强调了他做科学的方式。我的意思是，他确实是一位超级明星，与查尔斯·达尔文和其他我们可以提到的人并列。所以我们一直在谈论尼古拉·瓦维洛夫，他从许多方面来看是世界上
seminal plant geneticists, but also a scientist who has a very pointed reason for his work. He doesn't want any Russian, really any human, to die again because of famine. Over time, this remarkable humanitarian way of doing science gains Vavlov a lot of followers, both in terms of the science and his altruism. And over his career, Vavlov does something that's pretty incredible. He and his team of scientists gather hundreds of thousands of different kinds of seeds from 64 countries. It takes over 100 different expeditions to do this. He's like Russia's Indiana Jones of Seed collection. And he is super charismatic, he's handsome, he's good at raising money, but he's not without his detractors.
开创性的植物遗传学家之一，但也是一位对他的工作有非常明确理由的科学家。他不希望任何俄罗斯人，实际上任何人类，再因为饥荒而死亡。随着时间的推移，这种非凡的人道主义科学研究方式为瓦维洛夫赢得了许多追随者，无论是在科学还是他的利他主义方面。在他的职业生涯中，瓦维洛夫做了一件非常不可思议的事情。他和他的科学家团队从64个国家收集了数十万种不同的种子。这花费了100多次不同的探险才完成。他就像俄罗斯的种子收集版印第安纳·琼斯。他非常有魅力，英俊，擅长筹款，但他并非没有批评者。
Everybody famous has some haters, and Vavlov's got a problem. That problem's name is Trophim Lysenko. Lysenko starts out as a student of Vavlov, and Vavlov encourages him. But then Lysenko gets into this weird pseudoscience that rejects the idea of genetics, and he becomes this like anti-science-based agriculture guy,
每个名人都有一些黑粉，瓦维洛夫也有一个问题。那个问题的名字叫特罗菲姆·李森科。李森科最初是瓦维洛夫的学生，瓦维洛夫鼓励他。但后来李森科陷入了一种拒绝遗传学概念的奇怪伪科学，他变成了一个反科学的农业专家，
which is little odd because he also becomes the head of the Academy of Agricultural Sciences. Lysenko doesn't like Vavlov, they are rivals now, and Lysenko gains the ear and the favor of Stalin. It's August of 1940, you can almost guess what happens next. Vavilov was out on another collecting expedition in the Caucasus, found what he believed was a new subspecies of wild wheat that could be very effective because it was so drought tolerant. And as he was coming back to his vehicle,
这有点奇怪，因为他也成为了农业科学院的院长。李森科不喜欢瓦维洛夫，他们现在是竞争对手，李森科获得了斯大林的青睐。那是1940年8月，你几乎可以猜到接下来会发生什么。瓦维洛夫正在高加索进行另一次收集探险，发现了被他认为是野生小麦的一个新亚种，它可能非常有效，因为它非常耐旱。当他回到车上时，
several black unmarked cars from the KGB or its predecessor showed up and without talking to any of the other dozen scientists on the expedition, Vavlov was scuttled away and disappeared from public sight. So Vavlov is thrown into a prison in Leningrad, A.Krad, aka St. Petersburg. His family doesn't know where he is, his colleagues don't know where he is, but they have a mission,
几辆来自克格勃或其前身的黑色无牌照汽车出现了，在没有与探险队的其他十几位科学家交谈的情况下，瓦维洛夫就被带走了，从公众视野中消失了。所以瓦维洛夫被扔进了列宁格勒（又名圣彼得堡）的一所监狱。他的家人不知道他在哪里，他的同事不知道他在哪里，但他们有一个使命，
Vavlov's mission, of preserving and studying the world's food crops, of killing off hunger forever. His mission has a headquarters. It's this building at 44 Hurston Street in St. Peter's Burke. His staff sort of came together, they adored this man and said, we can't let anything happen to this collection. We don't know what's going to happen. And so they put three to five of their staffers on duty 24 hours a day and sealed off 18 rooms because there was another threat about to hit St. Petersburg. The siege of Leningrad starts in 1941, a year after Vavlov disappears into a gulag. This prison is a stone's throw from his family home. Vavlov's family members pass by without even knowing he is right there in prison.
瓦维洛夫的使命，即保存和研究世界粮食作物，永远消灭饥饿。他的使命有一个总部。就是圣彼得堡赫尔森街44号的那栋楼。他的员工聚在一起，他们崇拜这个人，说我们不能让这个收藏发生任何事。我们不知道会发生什么。所以他们安排了三到五名员工24小时值班，并封锁了18个房间，因为还有另一个威胁即将袭击圣彼得堡。列宁格勒围城战始于1941年，也就是瓦维洛夫消失在古拉格的一年后。这座监狱离他家只有一箭之遥。瓦维洛夫的家人经过时甚至不知道他就被关在那里的监狱里。
The siege of Leningrad is unique in that it lasts almost the entire war, nearly 900 days. The city is cut off on the north by the Finnish army and the south by the Germans. And at the time, it is one of the most destructive attacks on a major city in known history, constant bombing, lack of food and water. People actually rush into the craters after bombs drop because water gathers in the craters. That's how they get their water. And through all of this, people are starving to death in Leningrad. Everyone, Russian soldiers, government officials, also the families of the scientists who are
列宁格勒围城战的独特之处在于它持续了几乎整个战争，近900天。这座城市在北部被芬兰军队切断，在南部被德国军队切断。在当时，这是已知历史上对大城市最具破坏性的攻击之一，不断的轰炸，缺乏食物和水。人们实际上在炸弹落下后冲进弹坑，因为水会聚集在弹坑里。这就是他们获取水的方式。在这一切过程中，列宁格勒的人们正在饿死。每个人，俄罗斯士兵，政府官员，还有那些科学家的家人，他们
protecting, secretly protecting this massive seed bank, they are putting the location of the bank and the fact that it is full of food, seeds, rice, legumes in the metaphorical vault. They are not telling anyone, and they are really freaking out, by the way, because Hitler is rumored to be really focused on capturing the seeds in this seed bank as part of his world domination efforts. So it really is a high stakes mission. So think of it.
正在秘密保护这个巨大的种子库，他们把银行的位置以及它装满食物、种子、大米、豆类的事实放在隐喻的金库里。顺便说一句，他们没有告诉任何人，他们真的吓坏了，因为有传言说希特勒真的专注于夺取这个种子库里的种子，作为他统治世界努力的一部分。所以这确实是一个高风险的任务。所以想一想。
You're starving to death. Your family is. You opt for staying in this very powerful, leopositioned, well-guarded building, and your weight is going down. Your immune system is going down. And as one of the curators said, when someone asked him, was it hard for all of you to try to keep defending the seeds when you could have eaten them to improve your own personal health? He said, well, it was hard to wake up in the morning. It was hard to get on our feet because we were so weak. It was hard to get our clothes on because it was cold, but it was not hard to protect those seeds. the P collection curator. Alexander Skuken took care of P's peanuts and other legumes. And he was one of the ones who died in the first year
你正在饿死。你的家人也是。你选择留在这个非常强大、位置优越、守卫森严的建筑里，你的体重在下降。你的免疫系统在下降。正如其中一位馆长所说，当有人问他，你们所有人试图保护种子，而你们本可以吃掉它们来改善自己的个人健康，这很难吗？他说，嗯，早上起床很难。站起来很难，因为我们太虚弱了。穿衣服很难，因为很冷，但保护那些种子并不难。豌豆收藏馆长。亚历山大·斯库肯照顾着豌豆、花生和其他豆类。他是第一年就死于
of the effects of starvation with his seed envelopes in his hand. We know that other people died of diseases carried by rats that they were trying to evict from eating the seeds. A rice collector named Demetri Ivanov, he died within just a few feet of a thousand packets of rice that just by boiling up water, cooking the rice could have saved his life. [♪ Music playing in background, playing a year and a half of eating frozen cabbage and moldy flour, he also died of starvation. He never made it out of the gulag. But the seeds survived, and so did the mission. The Spalbart Seed Vault in Norway is a direct descendant of Vavlov's work. And that building in St. Petersburg is now the Vavalov Institute of Plant Industry.
饥饿影响的人之一，手里还拿着种子信封。我们知道其他人死于老鼠携带的疾病，他们试图驱赶老鼠不让它们吃种子。一位名叫德米特里·伊万诺夫的水稻收集者，他死在离一千包大米仅几英尺远的地方，只要烧开水，煮熟大米就能救他的命。[背景音乐响起，吃了一年半冷冻卷心菜和发霉面粉，他也死于饥饿。他没能活着走出古拉格。但种子幸存了下来，使命也延续了下来。挪威的斯瓦尔巴种子库是瓦维洛夫工作的直接继承者。而圣彼得堡的那栋建筑现在是瓦维洛夫植物工业研究所。
You visited the Seed Vault in St. Petersburg a few years back. What was that like for you? In my years of doing science, I've only wept twice. And once was in Hawaii when I saw 15 different endangered species, the last individual of many of those species all sitting on one table in a nursery, and there were none of those species left in the wild.
你几年前参观了圣彼得堡的种子库。那对你来说是什么样的？在我从事科学研究的岁月里，我只哭过两次。一次是在夏威夷，当我看到15种不同的濒危物种，其中许多物种的最后一个个体都坐在苗圃的一张桌子上，而野外已经没有这些物种了。
I felt the same way when I saw the wall of photos of those 12 scientists, Russian scientists, who gave up their lives to save those seeds. I was brokenhearted. What did you see in their faces. The best that any of us can hope to be on behalf of our fellow creatures. Thanks so much for talking with us. Thank you. Bless you for your good work. So, Amory, let's go back to Marie Haga for a minute, whose team of scientists recently opened this fall-bard seed vault on that frozen island in the Arctic Ocean. Yes, so here's a question, Ben. If these countries store the seeds there for free, who's paying that fall-bard electric
当我看到那12位俄罗斯科学家的照片墙时，我也有同样的感觉，他们为了拯救这些种子献出了生命。我心碎了。你在他们的脸上看到了什么？我们所有人为了同类所能希望达到的最好状态。非常感谢你与我们交谈。谢谢。上帝保佑你的善行。那么，阿姆里，让我们回到玛丽·哈加那里谈一会儿，她的科学家团队最近在北冰洋那个冰冻的岛屿上打开了这个斯瓦尔巴种子库。是的，所以这里有一个问题，本。如果这些国家免费在那里储存种子，谁来支付斯瓦尔巴的电费？
bill? Like who pays for the seed vault to exist? Great question. I asked Marie this. Our organization is first and foremost funded by governments. But increasingly, the crop trust is trying to work with the private sector. And Marie gave me an example. We have just developed a conservation strategy for coffee. Coffee happens to be a very climate sensitive. And that is why we think that the major coffee companies over the world should
比如谁为种子库的存在买单？好问题。我问过玛丽。我们的组织首先是由政府资助的。但作物信托基金越来越多地试图与私营部门合作。玛丽给了我一个例子。我们刚刚制定了咖啡保护战略。咖啡恰好对气候非常敏感。这就是为什么我们认为世界上的大型咖啡公司应该
get involved in our work and also contribute to funding it. I for one am very glad that the organization trying to protect the world's food crops from a doomsday scenario is also working on keeping coffee around. Yeah, I think we're going to need coffee after the apocalypse. But for Marie, of course, it's bigger than coffee. You know, I consider it a great privilege to work on something so fundamentally important as safeguarding the diversity of crops. That job is really about safeguarding the basis for our food, naam and tomorrow and forever.
参与我们的工作并为之提供资金。我个人非常高兴，那个试图保护世界粮食作物免受末日情景影响的组织也在致力于保留咖啡。是的，我想世界末日之后我们需要咖啡。但对玛丽来说，当然，这比咖啡更重要。你知道，我认为从事像保护作物多样性这样根本重要的事情是一种巨大的特权。这份工作实际上是关于保护我们今天、明天和永远的食物基础。
There are other seed banks in the world and our very own Emmett Fitzgerald is going to tell us about one of them after this. Okay, so we're back with 99PI producer Emmett Fitzgerald and he's with us because he was actually looking into doing a story on Bavlov for our show, While Back, and it didn't pan out for a bunch of boring reasons. So when I heard the endless thread version, I was like, well, let's just play that one because we love the story. But you would actually done some interviews on the subject already. Yeah, and as I was researching it, I found out about this other seed bank. This one is based in Syria, and it's run by an organization called a Karda, and that stands for the International Center
世界上还有其他种子库，我们的埃米特·菲茨杰拉德将在之后告诉我们其中一个。好的，我们回到了99PI制作人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德身边，他在这里是因为他实际上一直在考虑为我们的节目做一个关于瓦维洛夫的故事，前段时间，由于一些无聊的原因没有成功。所以当我听到《无尽线索》的版本时，我想，好吧，我们就播放那个吧，因为我们喜欢这个故事。但你实际上已经就这个主题做了一些采访了。是的，当我研究它时，我发现了另一个种子库。这个位于叙利亚，由一个叫ICARDA的组织运营，代表国际干旱地区农业研究中心。
for Agricultural Research in Dry Areas. And I actually spoke with the former director of a Karda Mahmoud Sula. My name is Mahmoud Sula, the former director general of the International Center for Agriculture Research in dry areas. And just like Nikolai Vavlov, when Mahmoud was a young plant scientist, he set off on his own seed collecting journey. And where did he go? So he went through all these central Asian countries,
我实际上和ICARDA的前主任马哈茂德·索尔赫谈过。我叫马哈茂德·索尔赫，国际干旱地区农业研究中心前总干事。就像尼古拉·瓦维洛夫一样，当马哈茂德还是一位年轻的植物科学家时，他踏上了自己的种子收集之旅。他去了哪里？所以他走遍了所有这些中亚国家，
places like Jordan, Lebanon, Iraq, Turkey. I collected in Afghanistan in August 1974. And at that time Afghanistan was a peaceful country. I was a beautiful country. And I never forget the mountains of pistachio trees in Afghanistan. Mahmoud drove all over Afghanistan in this little Jeep looking for wild wild lentils and chickpeas and pistachios, like you heard him talking about. And he wasn't just inspired by Nikolai Vavlov, he was literally following in Vavlov's footsteps, or at least he was trying to. At that time, I had the map of Vavilo, where did he go? So I was trying to follow the roots. But rural Afghanistan is extremely mountainous,
约旦、黎巴嫩、伊拉克、土耳其等地方。我在1974年8月在阿富汗收集。那时阿富汗是一个和平的国家。我是一个美丽的国家。我永远不会忘记阿富汗的开心果树山。马哈茂德开着这辆小吉普车在阿富汗到处寻找野生扁豆、鹰嘴豆和开心果，就像你听到他谈论的那样。他不仅受到尼古拉·瓦维洛夫的启发，他实际上是在追随瓦维洛夫的脚步，或者至少他在尝试。那时，我有瓦维洛夫的地图，他去了哪里？所以我试图跟随路线。但阿富汗农村极其多山，
two mountainous for the Jeep, it turned out. We could not go to certain areas without going on a back of a horse or a donkey, because those areas are so narrow and so steep. But to be honest with you, even in 74, we could not follow what Vervilov did in the earlier years. And that's why you really admired this man. You know, he was certainly a remarkable person.
事实证明，对于吉普车来说太山了。我们不能在不骑马或驴的情况下进入某些地区，因为那些地区太窄太陡了。但老实说，即使在74年，我们也无法跟随瓦维洛夫早年的做法。这就是你真正钦佩这个人的原因。你知道，他确实是一个非凡的人。
So what happened to all the seeds that Mahmoud collected? So those seeds were the beginning of the Akarta collection. And Akarta basically works with farmers in dry parts of the world, and one of the ways that they help them is by conserving and also breeding drought tolerant varieties of different crops. And in order to do this, they've collected a huge variety of seeds from farmers all over the Middle East and North Africa. They've got one of the world's largest collections of drought-collarant seeds, including thousands of varieties
那么马哈茂德收集的所有种子发生了什么？所以那些种子是ICARDA收藏的开始。ICARDA基本上与世界干旱地区的农民合作，他们帮助他们的方法之一是通过保护和培育不同作物的耐旱品种。为了做到这一点，他们从整个中东和北非的农民那里收集了大量的种子。他们拥有世界上最大规模的耐旱种子收藏之一，包括数千个品种
of barley, and lentil, and phababines. And for years, this collection was stored in a facility in Aleppo, Syria, which I can see the problem. Right, and when violence broke out in that country in 2011, the plant scientists from Acarta started to get worried about their seeds. And so they sent some collection to other seed banks around the world.
的大麦、扁豆和蚕豆。多年来，这个收藏一直储存在叙利亚阿勒颇的一个设施中，我可以看到问题所在。没错，当2011年那个国家爆发暴力冲突时，ICARDA的植物科学家开始担心他们的种子。所以他们把一些收藏品送到了世界各地的其他种子库。
They were creating duplicates of the collection. You know, in order to safeguard all that material and then eventually they were forced to leave Aleppo. But we got the seeds out before the staff fully had to abandon the research station. This is Kerry Fowler and he's actually the founder of the Svalbard Global Seed Vault, which we heard about in the endless thread piece. And Fowler ended up calling up Mokmoud and inviting him to store some of the cardic seeds
他们正在创建收藏的副本。你知道，为了保护所有这些材料，最终他们被迫离开阿勒颇。但在员工不得不完全放弃研究站之前，我们把种子运出来了。这是凯里·福勒，他实际上是斯瓦尔巴全球种子库的创始人，我们在《无尽线索》的片段中听到了这个。福勒最终打电话给马哈茂德，邀请他储存一些ICARDA的种子
up in the Norwegian Arctic. We got them up to Svalbard when it became clear that those researchers were not going to be able to go back to their institution and they had reestablished themselves in Morocco in 11 and they asked for their seed collection back so they could reestablish their seed bank. And so this was actually the first time that anyone had taken seeds back out of the Svalbard seed vault. And they used those seeds that had been stored there in that tunnel in the mountain to create two nude seed banks, one in Morocco and one in Lebanon.
在挪威北极。当很明显那些研究人员无法回到他们的机构时，我们把它们运到了斯瓦尔巴，他们在11年重新在摩洛哥建立了基地，他们要求取回他们的种子收藏，以便他们可以重建他们的种子库。所以这实际上是第一次有人从斯瓦尔巴种子库中取回种子。他们利用那些储存在山里隧道里的种子创建了两个新的种子库，一个在摩洛哥，一个在黎巴嫩。
So it's almost like they had this external backup hard drive for their computer. Even if something happens to the physical computer, you've still got all the data in this case, all the seeds, with all their genetic material, backed up somewhere else to start a new seed bank, somewhere else. Yeah, yeah, that's exactly right. That's an analogy that a lot of people use. And you know, there are seeds in a carda's collection that you can't find anywhere else.
所以这几乎就像他们为电脑准备了一个外部备份硬盘。即使物理电脑出了问题，你仍然有所有数据，在这种情况下是所有种子，以及它们所有的遗传物质，备份在其他地方以启动一个新的种子库，在其他地方。是的，是的，完全正确。这是很多人使用的类比。你知道，在ICARDA的收藏中有一些你在其他任何地方都找不到的种子。
So the consequences of not having that backup could be catastrophic. You know, in the past, this would likely, this kind of event, like likely have led to extinction. And in this case, I think it's pretty clear that that would be the extinction of something terribly valuable to world agriculture, because you can imagine that drought and heat tolerant varieties of wheat and barley and lentils chickpea and such are going to be in high demand, and that's the place you go to get them. It's really fascinating to hear a story of the seed bank not just being this potential to save us, but really it was used as it was meant to be to take in seeds and then send them out into the world to stop what could be a potential extinction of a whole species.
所以没有那个备份的后果可能是灾难性的。你知道，在过去，这种情况很可能导致灭绝。在这种情况下，我认为很明显这将是对世界农业极其有价值的东西的灭绝，因为你可以想象耐旱和耐热的小麦、大麦、扁豆、鹰嘴豆等品种将会有很大的需求，而那是你去获取它们的地方。听到种子库不仅是拯救我们的潜力，而且确实被按预期使用，接收种子然后将它们发送到世界各地以阻止整个物种潜在灭绝的故事，真是太迷人了。
It's kind of stunning to watch in action. It's interesting as people refer to it often as the Doomsday Vault and there's this kind of this kind of expectation that it's just waiting around for the apocalypse so that we could then use these seeds to regrow, restart our civilization or something, but Fowler actually sees it as having a much more active role as this kind of like, you know, this sort of backup hard drive for other seat banks around the world. So that if you run into trouble, you can store your seats there
看着它付诸实践真是令人震惊。有趣的是，人们经常把它称为“末日金库”，有一种期望，认为它只是在等待世界末日，这样我们就可以利用这些种子重新种植、重启我们的文明之类的，但福勒实际上认为它扮演着更积极的角色，就像这种，你知道，这种为世界各地其他种子库准备的备份硬盘。所以如果你遇到麻烦，你可以把你的种子储存在那里
and then take them out when you need them again. It seems like they're truly inspired by Vavlov's work. Yeah, yeah, I mean, in Vavlov, obviously, like at the turn of the early 20th century was super concerned about food security for Russia, and the idea was like, we've got to have our genetic diversity protected. And obviously people were willing to die for that with the idea that Russia needed these seeds on the other side of the war.
然后在你需要的时候再取出来。看起来他们确实受到了瓦维洛夫工作的启发。是的，是的，我的意思是，瓦维洛夫显然在20世纪初非常关心俄罗斯的粮食安全，想法是我们需要保护我们的遗传多样性。显然，人们愿意为此牺牲，认为俄罗斯在战争的另一边需要这些种子。
And I think the challenges are different, obviously, today, and more global potentially, but when you think about the importance for all of us of protecting our genetic diversity, it's inspiring. And a lot of these people were continued to be inspired by Vavalova. Everyone I spoke with was referred back to him very fondly. I mean, so much so that they literally followed in his footsteps. Right, right. Which doesn't seem all that practical.
我认为今天的挑战显然不同，而且可能更全球化，但当你想到保护我们的遗传多样性对我们所有人的重要性时，这是鼓舞人心的。而且这些人中的许多人继续受到瓦维洛夫的启发。我交谈过的每个人都被非常深情地提及他。我的意思是，以至于他们实际上追随了他的脚步。对，对。这看起来并不那么实用。
Right, right. I mean, yeah, and his, you know, the work that he did on, on kind of a centers of diversity around the world and how he thought about seeds were very much like ahead of their time. And people still refer back to him and his ideas have relevance today. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Ben Brock Johnson and Amri Seavritson, mixed and sound designed by John Parade and Paul Vegas, and Music by Squature.
对，对。我的意思是，是的，他在世界各地的多样性中心所做的工作，以及他如何思考种子，非常超前。人们仍然参考他，他的想法在今天仍然具有相关性。《99%隐形》本周由本·布洛克·约翰逊和阿姆里·西弗森制作，由约翰·帕拉德和保罗·维加斯混音和声音设计，音乐由Squature创作。
This story originally aired on Endless Thread, which is a production of WBUR, Boston's NPR station in partnership with Reddit. Iris Adler is the executive are on Endless Thread, which is a production of WBUR, Boston's NPR station, in partnership with Reddit. Iris Adler is the executive producer of Endless Thread, Michael Pope is the advisor and Reddit. For my team, Senior Producer Katie Mingle, Senior Editor Delaney Hall and Producer Emmett Fitzgerald help bring this one home. The rest of the team is Avery Trophman, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Lee, Taren Mazza, Shree Vusive, Sean Riel, Digital Director, Kirk Colstad, and me Roman Mars.
这个故事最初在《无尽线索》播出，这是WBUR（波士顿NPR电台）与Reddit合作制作的节目。艾里斯·阿德勒是《无尽线索》的执行制片人，迈克尔·波普是顾问和Reddit。对于我的团队，高级制片人凯蒂·明格尔，高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔和制片人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德帮助完成了这一集。团队的其他成员是艾弗里·特罗夫曼、乔·罗森伯格、薇薇安·李、塔伦·马扎、什里·武西夫、肖恩·里尔，数字总监柯克·科尔斯塔德，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。
They're all loving of us now. We are a project of 91.7KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in Beautiful, Downtown, Oakland, California. 99% Invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. You can find us all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Orc.
他们现在都爱我们。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的广播街制作。《99%隐形》是PRX旗下Radio Topia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。你可以在radiotopia.fm找到我们所有人。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与关于该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上@我，罗曼·马尔斯，或者@节目99PI Orc。
We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But if you want a link and want to learn more about Endless Threat, the show we featured this week, which is very good, and I hope you enjoyed it, and I hope you subscribe to it. Go to 99mpi.org. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上也有账号。但如果你想要一个链接并想了解更多关于《无尽线索》的信息，这是我们本周特别呈现的节目，它非常好，我希望你喜欢它，也希望你订阅它。请访问99mpi.org。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。